it's really good to understand how
people were living here for centuries
and millennia before Europeans came over
and really understanding all the food
and flavors that they were utilizing
my name is Sean Sherman I own the
company the sous-chef our company
focuses on indigenous foods basically we
have removed all European influence
we've cut out completely in our cuisine
things like dairy flour from wheat
processed sugar processed foods in
general we're not even using beef pork
or chicken so what we're doing right now
is we have a pop-up dinner featuring a
guest chef from the southwest from the
talented chef Carlos Baca and we are
putting on a five course dinner to
really showcase the food and flavors of
his region things like elk quail Chola
buds dried mushrooms though my name is
Carlos bacca I am from the southern new
reservation in southwestern Colorado
been in the food industry for 20 years
with the sole focus on indigenous foods
now for almost 6 1 things about myself
with my food is that I very heavy on
foraging so a lot of what is going to be
here today I gotten up in the San Juan
Mountains in Colorado out in the desert
in New Mexico my interest in all of this
really just comes from my own heritage
because I grew up on Pine Ridge
Reservation in South Dakota for me just
having a long career as a chef in the
Minneapolis area and I tried many
different cuisines that just made sense
at a certain point to really go back to
my own heritage because there was so
little representation of Native America
their humanity has walked away from the
symbiotic relationship and eating with
the seasons this dinner is very much you
know what did I have stored for the
winter to understand what Native
American food is it's really just
looking back at history and looking back
at regions and understanding how people
utilized wild foods and agriculture and
the wild game that was their cooking
techniques they utilize food
preservation techniques we prioritize
all of our purchasing from indigenous
vendors first off so for example we buy
all of our fish from the Red Lake
reservation and we buy over all of our
hand harvested wild rice from various
reservations throughout Minnesota we
want to explore all the areas of the US
and Mexico and Canada and Alaska and
really just work to record a lot of
these foods and the names that are in
those regions and you know just really
trying to get it out there because
unfortunately in the US and Canada a lot
of these food systems were almost wiped
off the map completely
[Music]
you